How exactly is it that a person who is not gay comes to believe, really believe, that they are gay for two years? Well, one of the contributing editors to this very radio program, Nancy Updike, had that experience herself. And she says, she did not just turn itself into any kind of gay person, no, no no. In her case, it was total, complete, full-hearted unambiguous commitment.
一个人明明不是同性恋，怎么会真的相信自己是同性恋，而且一信就是两年呢？这个广播节目的特约编辑之一，南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）就亲身经历过这种事。她说，她可不只是随便把自己变成那种同性恋，不，绝对不是。在她的案例中，这是一种彻底的、完全的、全心全意的、毫无歧义的投入。
Completely completely and utterly. I worked at a gay newspaper. I only hung out with gay people. In my spare time, I read about gay history. I dressed like a dyke. You know me now as kind of a femmy person.
完全、彻底且毫无保留。我在一家同性恋报社工作。我只和同性恋者交往。闲暇时，我阅读同性恋历史。我的打扮就像个女同性恋。你们现在看我，觉得我挺有女人味的。
Yeah, kind of a very femmy person.
没错，确实挺有女人味的。
Yeah. I cut my hair short. And I didn't wear any makeup. And I sort of dressed to hide my body. I had male friends that I called Mary.
是的。我把头发剪得很短。我不涂任何化妆品。我穿衣服也是为了遮挡身材。我有几个男性朋友，我管他们叫“玛丽”。
And so was there any kind of limit to your gayness?
那么，你的“同性恋身份”有什么局限性吗？
Yeah. The limit was that I really kind of couldn't bring myself to actually sleep with women.
有。局限就是，我真的没法让自己去跟女性发生性关系。
So that's seems like that would be kind of a problem.
那听起来确实是个问题。
It was. It was. I mean, at the time, it was sort of like, well, I'm in this difficult transition. And I'm sure I'm just about to do that. You know, it's like, yeah, yeah, I'll get to that. You know, it was like a loose end I hadn't tied up yet. It's like that squeaky door to the shed. You keep meaning to fix it. And every weekend it's like, I guess I forgot to fix the squeaky door. I mean, I just didn't want to. I just didn't want to.
确实是。我是说，当时我觉得，好吧，我正处于这个困难的过渡期。我肯定很快就会迈出那一步了。就像是，嗯，我会做到的。那就像一个还没解开的死结。就像棚屋那扇吱呀作响的门，你一直想修好它，但每个周末你都会说，哎呀，我好像又忘了修那扇门。其实，我就是不想做。我只是不想做。
So how does somebody who feels that way come to think that they're gay in the first place? When Nancy had just gotten out of college, she moved into the city. Her parents were going through a bitter divorce. All her college relationships with boys had been disasters. That's how it felt at the time anyway.
那么，一个有这种感觉的人，最初是怎么会认为自己是同性恋的呢？南希刚大学毕业时，搬到了城里。她的父母正经历一场痛苦的离婚。她在大学里与男生建立的所有关系都是一场灾难。至少当时她是这么觉得的。
I was really unhappy. And I felt that this must be the explanation. I can't make these relationships work. They seem so awful. Part of what was awful is that I never trusted them. All my close friends are women. And I love my women friends. And it just seemed like sort of a short leap to like well, maybe I'm in love. Maybe that's what's going on. Maybe that's the problem.
我当时非常不开心。我觉得这一定就是原因所在。我处理不好这些关系。它们看起来太糟糕了。糟糕的部分原因在于我从不信任他们。我所有亲密的朋友都是女性。我爱我的女性朋友。这看起来就像是很短的一步之遥，我想，也许我恋爱了。也许这就是原因。也许这就是问题所在。
Right, you had heard stories about people like you where their relationships hadn't worked out and they were unhappy all the time. And it turns out they were gay. That was the problem.
对，你听说过一些像你这样的人的故事，他们的关系不顺利，整天都不开心。结果发现他们是同性恋。这就是问题的根源。
Yeah. Yeah. And it's like a snowball rolling downhill. Once you get the ball started you start to accumulate evidence in your mind that that's in fact the case. Remember that little friend you had in fourth grade, well maybe you loved her. You guys were so close. And maybe the fact that you like to wear pants, well that's part of it. You were a little butch. You liked to wear pants in high school when other girls liked to wear skirts.
是的。就像滚雪球一样。一旦球开始滚动，你就会在脑海中不断积累证据，证明事实确实如此。想起你在四年级时交的那个好朋友，嗯，也许你爱她。你们当时那么亲密。也许你喜欢穿裤子这一点也是原因之一。你有点像“假小子”。当别的女孩喜欢穿裙子时，你在高中喜欢穿裤子。
You really start to-- or at least I did-- really start to sort of put everything together to make that the story. Because I really, really, really wanted to believe this story.
你真的开始——或者至少我是这样——把一切都拼凑起来，使之成为那个故事。因为我真的、真的、非常渴望相信这个故事。
Do you remember the first step you took?
你还记得你迈出的第一步吗？
Oh, well the very first step was probably breaking up with my boyfriend. But the step after that, I joined a lesbian feminist reading group. And it was just like history, herstory, and humanity, and huwomanity. I mean, I knew at the time this is not helping me.
哦，第一步大概是和我男朋友分手。但那之后的一步，我加入了一个女同性恋女性主义读书小组。那里全都是历史、她的故事（herstory）、人类，以及人女性（huwomanity）。我是说，我当时就知道这对我没帮助。
So for two years, this is how it went. Nancy was a reporter for the Philadelphia Gay News. She thought of herself as gay. Gay men and women would talk about how they grew up feeling like they were so different from their families, biding their time until they could leave home and be themselves. And Nancy felt like that was her story too. It had her story, except for the gay part.
就这样，这种情况持续了两年。南希是《费城同性恋新闻》的一名记者。她认为自己是同性恋。同性恋男女们会谈论他们如何从小就觉得与家人格格不入，一直等待时机离开家，去做回自己。南希觉得这也是她的故事。除了同性恋的部分，其他都很符合。
Nancy had never wanted to marry or have kids. And she loved that now she was surrounded by people who didn't want to marry or have kids. After a while, she did start to go out with a woman. But it was awkward and it was terrible. And reality started to set in. Little things would happen that would make her question what she was doing.
南希从未想过结婚或生子。她喜欢现在被一群不想结婚或生子的人包围着。过了一段时间，她确实开始和一个女人约会。但那很尴尬，也很糟糕。现实开始显露。一些小事不断发生，让她质疑自己在做什么。
One day one of her coworkers, a gay man, was heading out of the office for lunch.
一天，她的一位同事，一个男同性恋，正要离开办公室去吃午饭。
He came up behind me and he started rubbing my back, giving me a shoulder rub. It was kind of like the plug in the socket. It was just electric. It was the first time I had been touched on my skin by a man in a couple of years. In my head, I was just like Nancy, you've got to give this up.
他走到我身后，开始揉我的背，给我做肩部按摩。那感觉就像插头插进了插座。电流瞬间通遍全身。这是几年来第一次有男人触碰我的皮肤。我在心里对自己说：南希，你得放弃这种生活了。
Within a week, she started going around to people she knew. She'd already come out as a homosexual to family and to friends, which is a tough thing for anybody to do. And now, incredibly, she had to come out again as straight, which is even harder because she was so embarrassed. And it was hard not being part of a group anymore.
不到一周，她就开始去找她认识的人。她已经向家人和朋友出柜为同性恋了，这对任何人来说都是件难事。而现在，难以置信的是，她不得不再次出柜为异性恋，这更难，因为她感到太尴尬了。而且不再属于那个群体也很难受。
I felt so sad to leave that. I felt alone. I felt like, you know, I'm really on my own.
离开那个群体让我感到如此悲伤。我感到孤独。我觉得，你知道，我真的孤身一人了。
From WBEZ Chicago, It's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, My Experimental Phase, stories of people who are very unhappy who decide to become somebody different, and love being somebody different, and then have to choose whether to go back to being the person they once were.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》（This American Life），由公共广播国际（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天我们的节目主题是“我的实验阶段”，讲述那些非常不开心的人决定成为另一个人，享受成为那个另一个人，然后不得不选择是否要回到最初的自己的故事。
Act One of our program, Funny, You Don't Look Jewish. In that act, a man who's living essentially like a very devout, 19th century Polish villager, jumps forward two centuries, starts watching TV, and changes very, very fast. Act Two, Miami Vices. In that act, a middle school students switches schools and tries out an entirely new personality. Stay with us.
节目第一幕，“有趣，你看上去不像犹太人”。在这一幕里，一个活得像个虔诚的19世纪波兰村民的男人，跳跃到了两个世纪后，开始看电视，并迅速发生了改变。第二幕，“迈阿密罪恶”。在这一幕里，一个中学生转学后，尝试了一种全新的性格。请继续收听。
Act One, That's Funny, You Don't Look Jewish. This story takes place in Williamsburg, a neighborhood in Brooklyn where different worlds collide, or at least wearily orbit around each other. There's hipster Williamsburg, which is filled with galleries, and studios, and restaurants, and night spots, and lots of aspiring artists and musicians. And then there's Hasidic Williamsburg, which is pretty much stuck in the 19th century.
第一幕，“有趣，你看上去不像犹太人”。这个故事发生在布鲁克林的威廉斯堡，一个不同的世界碰撞、或者至少是勉强围绕着彼此运转的街区。这里有充满画廊、工作室、餐厅和夜店，以及大量有抱负的艺术家和音乐家的嬉皮士威廉斯堡。还有基本上停留在19世纪的哈西德派威廉斯堡。
You've probably at least seen pictures of the Hasids at one point or another. These are the religious Jews who shun just about everything modern. The women all wear long dresses, most of them wear wigs. All the men wear identical black suits, white shirts, black hats, and they have that hair thing, you may have noticed, something called payes, the long curls that fall near their sideburns down their face in front of the ears.
你们可能至少在某个时候看过哈西德派的照片。他们是几乎拒绝一切现代事物的宗教犹太人。女人们都穿长裙，大多数人戴假发。所有男人都穿着一模一样的黑色西装、白衬衫、黑帽子，还有你们可能注意到的那种头发，叫做“裴伊”（payes），即垂在脸颊两侧、耳朵前面的长卷发。
These two Williamsburgs don't interact much. They hardly even acknowledge each other except on very rare occasions. David Segal is a staff writer and the former rock critic at the Washington Post. And he tells the story of one of those occasions.
这两个威廉斯堡几乎没有交集。他们甚至几乎不承认对方的存在，除了极少数情况。大卫·西格尔（David Segal）是《华盛顿邮报》的特约撰稿人，也是前摇滚乐评人。他讲述了其中一次难得的交集。
It's hard to imagine this about a group of people living one subway stop from Manhattan. But the Hasids of Williamsburg know next to nothing about the world outside their enclave. And that's the way they want it. The bible, they say, tells them to keep separate from everyone else, to build boundaries that are as thick as possible. Their outfits are meant to set them apart. And then there's the language barrier. Though nearly all of these people are born and raised here in the US, Yiddish is the only language most of them truly know.
很难想象这发生在离曼哈顿只有一个地铁站距离的一群人身上。但威廉斯堡的哈西德人对他们聚集区以外的世界几乎一无所知。这就是他们想要的状态。他们说，圣经告诉他们要与他人保持距离，建立尽可能厚的界限。他们的装束就是为了将他们区分开来。还有一个语言障碍。尽管这些人几乎都是在美国出生长大的，但意第绪语是他们大多数人真正掌握的唯一语言。
None of us know English. We don't talk English at home. We study English class one hour a day.
我们都不懂英语。我们在家里不说英语。我们每天只上一小时的英语课。
This is Chaim. He didn't want us to mention his last name, for good reasons as you'll find out later.
这是海姆（Chaim）。出于后面你们会明白的原因，他不想让我们提到他的姓氏。
Boys and girls are completely divided. There's no movies. We don't know anything about the world. We don't know any celebrities.
男孩和女孩是完全分开的。没有电影。我们对世界一无所知。我们不认识任何名人。
Had you heard of MTV?
你听说过MTV吗？
Not even close. We didn't even know radio. We never heard radio, not even AM. You know what I mean?
差得远了。我们甚至不知道什么是收音机。我们从没听过收音机，连调幅电台都没听过。你明白我的意思吗？
So if someone had mentioned the Rolling Stones, or U2, or other rock bands, you would not have recognized those names?
所以如果有人提到滚石乐队、U2或其他摇滚乐队，你认不出这些名字吗？
Rolling Stones, I would think it's something that injured somebody. I wouldn't know what Rolling Stones mean.
滚石乐队（Rolling Stones），我会以为是某种伤到人的东西。我不知道滚石乐队意味着什么。
At the time this story begins, one night, years ago, Chaim is 20 and single, which in the Hasidic community, is a problem. The problem though, has a highly ritualized solution. Through matchmakers, the groom-to-be is sent on what sounds more like a job interview than a date. The guy meets the father of the potential bride and he peppers the young man with questions. If the father likes the answers, the guy meets the daughter. And after a brief meeting or two, the pair decide whether to marry.
故事开始的时候，那是一晚，几年前，海姆20岁，单身，这在哈西德社区是个问题。不过，这个问题有一个高度仪式化的解决方案。通过媒人，未婚夫被派去进行一次听起来更像求职面试而不是约会的活动。男方会见潜在新娘的父亲，父亲会向年轻人抛出一连串问题。如果父亲喜欢他的回答，男方就会见到那个女孩。在见面一两次之后，两人决定是否结婚。
Well, Chaim has been on a few these outings. And he kept flunking the father interview. On the night in quesiton, his would have been father-in-law asked Chaim if he would stay in school, in yeshiva and study full time. It would be prestigious having a scholar in the family. But Chaim had told him the truth, that yeshiva didn't interest him much. When he was rejected, not for the first time, his family thought he'd screwed up again.
海姆参加过几次这样的“面试”。他一直没能通过父亲那一关。那天晚上，未来的岳父问海姆是否会继续上学、在经学院（yeshiva）全职学习。家中有一位学者是很有面子的事。但海姆对他说了实话，他并不怎么对经学院感兴趣。当他再次被拒时，他的家人认为他又搞砸了。
When I got home, everybody was telling me, why didn't you tell them at least that you would? Then you don't have to do it. Everybody was on me. And I was not very happy because most of us go at the age of 18, 19, 20, 21. Most of my friends were married already. Some of them had kids. I felt like the blame was on me why I am not married or something like that.
当我回家时，每个人都在问我，你为什么至少不假装答应呢？反正你不一定要真做。大家都盯着我。我不怎么开心，因为我们大多数人在18、19、20、21岁时都会结婚。我的朋友大多数已经结婚了。有些人甚至有孩子了。我感觉我为什么没结婚完全是我的错。
Now to understand what happens next, you have to know that Chaim was the Hasidic version of a rebellious teen. He snuck away to watch an American movie or two, and had recently become a baseball fan. And on a few occasions when he felt especially hassled by his family, he headed to a bar for a beer, which is what he did this evening. A local bar, called the Right Bank where a man named Billy Campion happened to be performing.
要理解接下来发生的事，你必须知道海姆是哈西德版的叛逆少年。他曾溜出去看过一两部美国电影，最近还成了棒球迷。有几次当他感到被家人特别骚扰时，他会去酒吧喝杯啤酒，他那天晚上就是这么做的。那是一家叫“右岸”（Right Bank）的当地酒吧，碰巧有一个叫比利·坎皮恩（Billy Campion）的人在表演。
Billy was jumping up and down on the bar like a gorilla in a cage bellowing at the top of his lungs playing a guitar. Chaim watched and he was amazed.
比利像笼子里的猩猩一样在吧台上跳上跳下，嘶吼着大声唱歌，还弹着吉他。海姆看着，惊呆了。
It was just loose. It was just, you know, fly. Everything was rocking. He was performing while he was jumping on chairs and throwing all kinds of stuff. It was cool to see how somebody was so free. And that's exactly what I wanted. I was so tight at that time. I wanted to get loose a little bit.
他太自由了。一切都摇滚起来了。他在椅子上跳来跳去，扔着各种东西在表演。看到一个人如此自由真是太酷了。这正是我想做的。我当时活得太压抑了。我想要稍微释放一下。
So during the break, I see this very tall, Hasidic guy sitting at the bar, smoking a cigarette, drinking a beer, and watching the baseball game.
所以休息期间，我看到这个非常高的哈西德人在吧台坐着，抽着烟，喝着啤酒，看着棒球比赛。
This is Billy Campion, known to the world and indie music fans as Vic Thrill. On the night that he was pogoing on the bar, Billy lived a few blocks and several centuries away from Chaim in the other Williamsburg. Billy wears space glasses and secondhand tuxedos, and his hair is spot dyed a different color every couple weeks. But he's one of these guys who greets everyone on his block by name, from other scenesters, to cashiers who worked for bodegas. So it's bugged him for years that there's this huge population in his neighborhood, the Hasids, whom he knew nothing about and never spoke to. And a few weeks prior to the show at the Right Bank, he decided to do something about it.
这就是比利·坎皮恩，在独立音乐迷眼中他叫“Vic Thrill”。那天晚上他在吧台上蹦跳的时候，比利住得离海姆只有几个街区远，但他住的是另一个威廉斯堡，一个精神上相隔数世纪的街区。比利戴着太空眼镜，穿着二手燕尾服，头发每几周就会染一种不同的颜色。但他就是那种能叫出街上每个人名字的人，从其他搞艺术的人到杂货店的收银员，他都认识。所以，多年来他一直感到困惑，为什么在他的社区里有这么庞大的人群——哈西德人，他却对他们一无所知，也从未交谈过。在“右岸”演出的几周前，他决定做点什么。
I actually asked God if he would introduce me to a Hasidic Jew that wouldn't mind showing me about the culture. I wanted to relate, you know what I mean, to people who seemed so different.
我真的祈求上帝给我介绍一个不介意向我展示他们文化的哈西德犹太人。我想要建立联系，你懂我的意思吗，与那些看起来如此不同的人。
You actually prayed to God about this?
你真的为此祈祷过？
Yeah. I was standing in my place looking out my window. It faces south towards the Hasidic community. And I thought to myself, well, I need to bounce it off a satellite, you know what I mean, to get it over the top of the neighborhood. I figured I had to come in from above to get in there.
是的。我站在我的住处看着窗外。我的窗户朝南，正对着哈西德社区。我心想，好吧，我得把祈祷发射到卫星上，从邻居上方穿过去。我想我得从上面切入才能进去。
The night at the bar, though, Billy wasn't really thinking about any of that. He just spotted Chaim and introduced himself.
不过在酒吧的那晚，比利并没有想那么多。他只是看到了海姆，就走过去自我介绍。
So I started talking to him. And I didn't realize this is a godsend yet, you know. And I was like, how's it going? He's like hey, nice music. And I was like, thanks a lot man. I was like, you really liked it? I was surprised, you know?
我开始跟他聊天。那时我还没意识到这是天赐之物。我就问，怎么样？他说，嘿，音乐不错。我说，多谢了哥们。我说，你真的喜欢？我很惊讶，你知道吗？
I used to also make music, so you know, Hasidic songs. So when I saw Billy that night, I felt like OK, now I have a connection. There was never a Hasid that ever became a rocker.
我过去也创作音乐，比如哈西德歌曲。所以那天晚上见到比利，我觉得，好，现在我有联系了。从来没有一个哈西德人变成摇滚乐手。
I was like, I have a recording studio up the street. I would love to have you by some time, you know, if you really want to get these recordings down in a quality way. And he's like, oh, maybe I'll take you up on it. So I gave him  my phone number and I forgot about it.
我就说，我在街上有个录音棚。如果你真的想好好录音的话，我很乐意你什么时候过来。他说，哦，也许我会去的。于是我给了他电话号码，然后就忘了这事。
My fans didn't really show, I didn't feel, appreciation from my songs. My father never gives me a compliment. He doesn't even know how to take one. He's a very nice guy, my father. But he just doesn't know how to give a compliment. So when I had somebody that I was able to talk to, you know, I was totally for it, for him. And the first chance that I had to come to the studio, I snuck in here I was here.
我的粉丝并不怎么欣赏我的歌。我父亲从不给我任何赞美。他甚至不知道怎么夸人。我父亲是个很好的人。但他就是不知道怎么赞美。所以当我有一个能交谈的对象时，我全心全意地支持他。第一次有机会去录音棚时，我溜了过来。
I got a phone call one day. He said yeah, hello. And I was like, hi. He was like, this is Chaim. We met down at the bar the other night. I wanted to come check out your studio. So I was like, I would love that. You know what I mean? And he came here and next thing you know, he didn't leave for a year and a half.
一天我接到个电话。他说，喂，你好。我说，嗨。他说，我是海姆。我们那天晚上在酒吧见过。我想来看看你的录音棚。我说，太棒了。你懂我意思吧？他来了之后，接下来的事就是，他一年半都没走。
The here that Billy's talking about is a converted industrial garage, which served as the apartment, recording studio, prop warehouse, and party headquarters for Billy and a group of his friends. They called it the Vic Thrill Salon. It's here that Vic Thrill's musical debut, CE-5 was recorded. And if I can editorialize for a moment, it's really superb, one of the best albums of 2003. Sci-fi pop with lots of hooks, deadpan humor. Like Devo, but a little more raw.
比利说的这个地方是一个改建的工业车库，它既是公寓、录音棚，也是道具仓库，还是比利和他朋友们的聚会大本营。他们叫它“Vic Thrill沙龙”。Vic Thrill的首张音乐作品《CE-5》就是在这里录制的。如果我能发表一点个人观点的话，那真的太棒了，是2003年最好的专辑之一。科幻流行乐，有很多抓耳的旋律，冷面幽默。就像Devo乐队，但更原始一点。
[VIC THRILL MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIC THRILL 音乐播放中]
The Vic Thrill's Salon is sort of a thrift store version of Andy Warhol's factory. In any given moment, musicians with names like Trance Pop Loops or Saturn Missile could be jamming on the couch. People's with video cameras came and went. Rock and roll manager named Mary Mayhem who dealt cocaine from her purse was a regular. Into this chaos walked Chaim wearing a buttoned up black suit and a rabbinical beard. If he'd been searching for the polar opposite of his Hasidic life, he couldn't have done better. But what intrigued him the most, was something found in about just any den in the US. It was the television.
“Vic Thrill沙龙”有点像安迪·沃霍尔（Andy Warhol）工作室的廉价翻版。在任何时刻，可能都有名字叫“Trance Pop Loops”或“Saturn Missile”之类的音乐人在沙发上即兴演奏。拿着摄像机的人进进出出。一个叫玛丽·玛雅（Mary Mayhem）的摇滚乐经理人常把可卡因藏在钱包里卖。海姆穿着扣得严严实实的黑西装、留着拉比式的胡须，走进了这片混沌。如果他一直在寻找与哈西德生活截然相反的环境，那他选对了地方。但最让他着迷的，是美国几乎每个角落都能找到的东西：电视。
He watched everything, everything from like cheesy Aaron Spelling shows to like five straight hours of MTV.
他什么都看，从那种俗气的亚伦·斯佩林（Aaron Spelling）电视剧到连续五小时的MTV。
I would be able stay there about five hours or more. I would sit here. I was a heavy smoker. I was there for hours just watching, soaking in television.
我能在那里待五个多小时甚至更久。我就坐在那里。我是个老烟枪。我在那儿待几个小时，就只是看电视，沉浸在电视里。
His favorite channel, of all the channels he watched, was MTV because of the years he'd spent writing songs in his spare time. His stuff was mostly biblical prayers set to melodies he made up, sort of like this, his rendering, in Hebrew, of the 23rd Psalm.
在他看的所有频道中，他最喜欢MTV，因为他业余时间写了很多年歌。他的作品主要是根据他编造的旋律写的圣经祈祷文，比如这一段，他用希伯来语演绎的《诗篇第23篇》。
[CHAIM SINGING]
[海姆演唱中]
MTV caused Chaim to give up the Old Testament as a muse and starting writing pop in English. But the guy was the cultural equivalent of an unfrozen caveman. Everything was new. Nothing had context. You take someone like that and expose him to daily and lethal doses of music television, something strange is bound to happen.
MTV让海姆放弃了以旧约作为创作源泉，开始用英语创作流行音乐。但这个家伙简直就是文化意义上的“冷冻原始人”。一切都是新的。什么都没有背景。你带一个这样的人，让他每天接触致命剂量的音乐电视，奇怪的事情注定会发生。
He would not differentiate between Britney Spears and Eminem. He just thought music. Like that's good. That's not good. I like that. I don't like that. He didn't yet know anything about genres or what kind of demographic is into that. He just didn't care. So he was writing music that went from like very sensitive love songs about the show Pacific Blue .
他无法区分小甜甜布兰妮（Britney Spears）和埃米纳姆（Eminem）。他只是觉得音乐，“那是好的。那不好。我喜欢那个。我不喜欢那个。”他还不知道流派或观众群之类的概念。他根本不在乎。所以他写的歌从关于电视剧《太平洋蓝》（Pacific Blue）的非常感性的情歌，到各种奇怪的东西。
[SINGING] Midnight blue, you're so sweet when you come true. Pacific Blue.
[演唱中]午夜蓝，当你实现时，你是那么甜美。太平洋蓝。
I had this one song. It goes like this. [SINGING] When I wrap my arms around you I feel your heartbeat. It's a time bomb to explode. Love is the ammunition. Sparkle, sparkle, beautiful eyes. Twinkle, twinkle beautiful lips. Warm me, warm me, beautiful body. Oh you're such a hottie. The meal is being served, but you know what's being observed. A little touching under the table, whoa, who needs cable?
我有首歌是这样的：[演唱中]当我用双臂拥抱你，我感受到你的心跳。这是一个即将爆炸的定时炸弹。爱是弹药。闪烁，闪烁，美丽的眼睛。眨眼，眨眼，美丽的嘴唇。温暖我，温暖我，美丽的身体。哦，你真是个辣妹。餐点正在上菜，但你知道正在观察什么吗？桌下的小动作，哇，谁还需要有线电视呢？
And a lot of the stuff doesn't make sense like Welcome to the Millennium . [SINGING] And heals our wounds. A happiness, I never pretend.
还有很多内容根本不连贯，比如《欢迎来到千禧年》：[演唱中]治愈我们的伤口。一种幸福，我从未伪装。
Like, stuff wouldn't make sense.
就是这样，内容往往不合逻辑。
The problem was that my lyrics, usually when I did write, because my vocabulary was so small and my English was so poor, it was funny.
问题是，我的歌词，通常在我写的时候，因为我的词汇量太小，英语太差，所以显得很滑稽。
Like any kid who discovers music for the first time, this guy was blossoming at such an incredible rate of creativity, the most prolific being you've ever seen your life. And he's saying to me, he's like, you know, I'm on my way to Yeshiva and I'm singing these melodies on the sidewalk. And I have these melodies. And I have these good verbal ideas. But I go into Yeshiva and I start the class and I forget them And I just need a way to remember these things.
就像任何第一次发现音乐的孩子，这个家伙以惊人的速度在创造力上开花结果，这是你一生中见过最活跃的创作者。他对我说，你知道，我正要去经学院的路上，在人行道上哼唱着旋律。我有这些旋律，我有这些好的语言灵感。但我进了经学院开始上课，就全忘了。我需要一个记住这些东西的方法。
So I said, well, it would be good if you had like a portable cassette player or something like that. But he wasn't going to have one anytime soon. And his allowance is small. So I was like, you know what I do in a jam, I call my answering machine. And he heard that, man, and that was the solution right there. And he was like, oh, that's a good idea.
于是我说，好吧，如果你有个便携式卡带播放机之类的东西就太好了。但他不可能很快弄到。而且他的零花钱很少。所以我就说，你知道我在卡住时是怎么做的吗？我打给我自己的语音信箱。他听了，伙计，那正是解决方案。他说，哦，那是好主意。
Well I find that he doesn't have an answering machine. But, of course, I do.
我发现他没有语音信箱。但当然，我有。
[ANSWERING MACHINE VOICE] Message one.
[语音信箱语音]消息一。
[SINGING] Got no time, got no time to do it. Got no time, got no time, got no time to do it.
[演唱中]没时间，没时间做了。没时间，没时间，没时间做了。
It got to the point where I couldn't even check my own messages anymore because he was filling my answering machine with new song ideas from pay phones all over the city. Here's trucks whizzing by in the background. This guy is like [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. That's the keyboard line for the second verse of Midnight Blue . And then he hangs up the phone.
后来甚至连我自己都没法查自己的留言了，因为他一直在用全市各处的公用电话往我的语音信箱里填新的歌词灵感。背景里甚至能听到卡车飞驰而过的声音。这个家伙就像是……那是《午夜蓝》第二段的键盘伴奏线。然后他就挂了电话。
[ANSWERING MACHINE VOICE] Message six.
[语音信箱语音]消息六。
[SINGING] She comes from nowhere. [UNINTELLIGIBLE  PHRASE].
[演唱中]她从虚无中来。[听不清词句]。
I had become aggravated by him. Because he was coming around every day for no less than six hours a day and watching TV. I said, if I didn't have a TV, would you be coming over here? Is it my friendship that you're totally looking for or are you looking to watch some tube here. All right, all right, I've got to admit it. A TV, I'm addicted. I'm definitely addicted to the television and I need to do something about it.
我开始对他感到恼火。因为他每天都会来，待上至少六个小时看电视。我说，如果我没有电视，你还会过来吗？你到底是为了友谊才来的，还是为了看电视？好吧，好吧，我必须承认。电视，我上瘾了。我绝对是对电视上瘾了，我得做点什么。
And he had been pestering me to write music with him. And I kept putting him off and putting him off. This guy's a pain in the ass, whatever. And then it dawned on me. That's when I said, I was like, this is the moment. Yes, I'll definitely write some music with you. And I wanted to make it as easy as I could on myself. I just grabbed my guitar. I said, sing some of those lines to me there.
他一直在缠着我跟他写歌。我一直推三阻四。这家伙真是个讨债鬼，随便吧。然后我突然意识到：就是现在。我说，好，我绝对会跟你一起写歌。我想尽可能让自己轻松点。我拿过吉他，我说，唱几句那些歌词给我听听。
Welcome to the Millennium was the first song that we ever wrote together. And I said, sing the first verse to me. So he's like, OK, here's the first verse. The verse is: [SINGING] Here comes the night. There is no lights. It's so dark it looks like the end. A cold wind blows. A scary noise. A situation I'd never pretend.
《欢迎来到千禧年》是我们一起写的第一首歌。我说，唱第一段给我听。他说，好，这是第一段。歌词是：[演唱中]夜晚降临。没有光亮。如此黑暗，就像末日来临。冷风吹过。惊悚的噪音。一种我从未伪装的处境。
So I was like, OK, that's the first verse. So is that, [SINGING WITH GUITAR] Here comes the night. There is no light. It looks like the sun came down to earth.
于是我说，好，那是第一段。那歌词是这样吗：[弹着吉他演唱]夜晚降临。没有光亮。看起来像是太阳落到了地球上。
So I just like put chords like directly to the vocal line. And this is like how I proceeded from that point on. [SINGING WITH GUITAR] A cold wind blows. A scary noise. A situation, I'd never pretend. Welcome to the Millennium. [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] for the Millennium. [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
我就直接把和弦配到了旋律线上。从那以后我就是这样处理的：[弹着吉他演唱]冷风吹过。惊悚的噪音。一种我从未伪装的处境。欢迎来到千禧年……
So that's what was happening. And then finally I had to start booking shows.
事情就是这样发生的。最后我得开始帮他接演出了。
The first gig that I got him, the first gig was at this place Joe's Pub, which is like a high profile joint. It's like what I would consider to be like a double velvet rope affair. I mean, you have to be somebody to get into the place.
我帮他接的第一个演出是在Joe's Pub，那是一个很有名的场馆。我认为那属于需要过两道天鹅绒警戒线的地方。我是说，你必须是个有头有脸的人才能进去。
I mean there's like James Iha, the guitarist from Smashing Pumpkins, standing on line with some kind of supermodel. These are the kind of people that are standing on line to get in.
我是说，像捣蛋南瓜乐队（Smashing Pumpkins）的吉他手詹姆斯·伊哈（James Iha）那样的人，都要跟超级名模排队等着进去。
On the night the performance, Vic and the band headed onstage in their regular, outlandish gear. Chaim is dressed in traditional Hasid clothes, black pants, white shirt, yarmulke. He was introduced at the craziest Jew since Goldberg, the professional wrestling star.
演出当晚，Vic和乐队穿着他们一贯夸张的演出服上台了。海姆穿的是传统的哈西德服装：黑裤子、白衬衫、小圆帽。他被介绍为“自职业摔角明星高德伯格（Goldberg）以来最疯狂的犹太人”。
I felt like that scene in Young Frankenstein . Ladies and gentlemen, the monster. And then this guy comes out on stage. That's what it was like. He came out on stage. People were just like, what the hell is this?
我觉得就像《新科学怪人》（Young Frankenstein）里的那一幕。女士们先生们，怪物来了。然后这个家伙走上舞台。就是那种感觉。他走上台时，人们就想，这到底是什么鬼？
His performance was like a mixture between Eminem or Snoop Dogg, you know like pointing in people's faces, just the most demonstrative hand gestures you've ever seen in your life. And then throwing kicks up in the air like a Hasidic wedding. He's mixing like this Jewish dancing with what he's seen on MTV.
他的表演像是埃米纳姆（Eminem）和史努比狗狗（Snoop Dogg）的混合体，你知道，那种指着人的脸，做出你这辈子见过最夸张的手势。然后踢腿踢向空中，就像哈西德婚礼上跳舞那样。他把犹太舞蹈和他从MTV上学来的东西混合在一起。
And it was so over the top. At first people were like a dog that had just been shown a card trick. Like people were baffled. And then all of a sudden, I was like, ladies and gentlemen, this is a real Hasidic man. And then the place just out of their seats hit the dance floor and went ballistic. They loved it. They flipped. And he became like an instant star. He was like this underground star.
那表演太过火了。起初人们像是一只刚看了纸牌戏法的狗一样，完全被搞糊涂了。然后突然，我说：“女士们先生们，这是一位真正的哈西德人。”接着，全场人们都从座位上跳起来冲向舞池，彻底疯狂了。他们爱死这种表演了。他们彻底沦陷了。他成了一个瞬间的明星。他成了一个地下明星。
Coming up, putting the Sabbath back into Black Sabbath. The life of an underground Hasidic glam rock star, that's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
稍后回来，把安息日放回“黑色安息日”。关于一位地下哈西德华丽摇滚明星的生活，一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, My Experimental Phase, stories of people who take on a new identity as a lark and then start to face some serious choices.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，带来各种不同的故事。今天的主题是“我的实验阶段”，讲述那些人为了好玩而采取新身份，然后开始面临严峻选择的故事。
David Segal's story about Chaim continues. A warning that they mentioned the existence of sex in a general way in what's about to follow. The story at this point, by day, Chaim was a typical young Hasid living with his parents. By night, he was on the rock scene, the underground rock scene. Here's David
大卫·西格尔关于海姆的故事继续。提醒一下，接下来提到的内容涉及了对性行为的一般性讨论。故事到了这个阶段，白天，海姆是个和父母住在一起的典型年轻哈西德人。晚上，他混迹于摇滚圈，地下摇滚圈。请听大卫的报道。
A typical day went like this. He'd get up in the morning, tell his mom and dad he was going to yeshiva, cut class, and head to Billy's. He'd watch TV, eat, talk, hang out, watch more TV, go home for dinner. Then on nights when he was performing, he'd head out again, this time with his concert outfit tucked into a bag.
典型的一天是这样的：他早起，告诉爸妈他要去经学院，实际上却逃课去比利那儿。他看电视、吃饭、聊天、消磨时间、看更多电视，然后回家吃晚饭。在有演出表演的晚上，他会再次出门，这次带着装在包里的演出服。
He was really getting into the costumery of what we were doing. So the only costumery he had was Purim clothes, which is, you know, the Jewish Halloween basically. They get all dressed up. And so he had all of his Purim clothes. So that became his gig outfits, like this gold sequined cape with gold tinsel. This big almost like Hebrew Flavor Flav style necklace. It was like superman style. He would show up Hasidic with a little bag or something like that. And then he would go into the bathroom and just transform.
他开始对我们搞的那套服装非常入迷。他唯一的演出服就是“普珥节”（Purim）的衣服，基本上就是犹太人的万圣节。他们会打扮得很隆重。所以那些衣服就成了他的演出服，比如这件带金色亮片的斗篷。还有这种硕大的、类似“Flavor Flav”风格的希伯来式项链。就像超人风格。他会以哈西德形象出现，带着个小包，然后去厕所里变身。
He said to me, I need a name. You guys got a name. You're Vic Thrill, you got Saturn Missile. Everybody needs a name. So I was thinking about maybe I should have one. I said, that's cool. Have you thought of anything. I thought of a couple. I got this one. I got this one that sounds kind of cool. I was like, what's that? He says, Curly Oxide.
他对我说，我需要一个名字。你们都有名字。你是Vic Thrill，你有Saturn Missile。每个人都需要名字。我在想也许我应该有一个。我说，那很酷。你想好了吗？我想到几个。我想到一个听起来挺酷的。我说，是什么？他说，“Curly Oxide”（卷发氧化物）。
Curly Oxide. It came in to me. You know I have payes, curls, curly. And then I wanted something like edgy. From what I've seen, the culture of music has to be some sort of a little edgy. Oxide came into me. I don't know why. So, Curly Oxide.
“Curly Oxide”。这是我想到的。你知道我有“裴伊”，那种卷发，所以是Curly（卷曲的）。然后我想要一点边缘感。从我看到的音乐文化来看，总得有点边缘感。Oxide（氧化物）就跳进了我脑海里。我不知道为什么。所以，Curly Oxide。
And I go, that's great. I played down my reaction. That's great, man. That's great. Why is it great? He was like already suspicious. Hasids are suspicious, man. They look right through you. Why is that great? He said, what does it mean? Well curly, you know. Yeah, I know what curly means. I got the payes. What about oxide? Oxide, oxide is rust. It's like on metal. If you leave it out in the rain, it turns orange. I don't know if I like that.
我说，那太棒了。但我掩饰了自己的反应。我说，那太棒了，伙计，太棒了。为什么棒？他已经开始怀疑了。哈西德人很疑神疑鬼，伙计。他们能看穿你。为什么棒？他说，那是什么意思？好吧，Curly，你知道。是的，我知道Curly的意思。我有卷发。那Oxide呢？Oxide，氧化物就是锈。金属上的那种。如果你把它放在雨里，它就会变成橙色。我不知道我喜不喜欢那个。
Oxide is oxidation. It's about something undergoing change, a transformation from one thing into another thing. I like that. I like the sound of that. Because I'm undergoing a transformation. I am undergoing a transformation into Curly Oxide.
Oxide（氧化物）是一种氧化过程。它是指某种东西经历变化，从一种物质转化为另一种物质。我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个词的发音。因为我正在经历一个转变。我正在经历一场变成Curly Oxide的转变。
Ladies and gentlemen, Curly Oxide.
女士们先生们，Curly Oxide。
[CURLY OXIDE MUSIC PLAYING]
[CURLY OXIDE音乐播放中]
So then you began performing pretty regularly with him? Did he get a reputation? Did people find out about him?
那你后来开始频繁地和他一起演出吗？他有名气吗？人们发现他的身份了吗？
Oh yeah, yeah. He would perform then regularly down at the Right Bank. And then we would have him come up and play for the bigger Vic Thrill shows, Mercury Lounge, Bowery Ballroom, the WestBeth Theater when that was still around. And people loved it.
哦，是的，是的。他后来经常在“右岸”演出。然后我们会让他过来为更大的Vic Thrill演出助阵，比如Mercury Lounge、Bowery Ballroom，还有WestBeth剧院（当时还没关闭）。人们都很喜欢。
[CURLY OXIDE MUSIC PLAYING]
[CURLY OXIDE音乐播放中]
This is Curly Oxide on a typical night at the Right Bank in a video recorded for the Vic Thrill Salon. The Right Bank is a cramped little club without a stage. The crowd gawks and dances. And Curly holds the microphone with both hands like someone's going to try to steal it from him.
这是Curly Oxide在“右岸”的一个典型夜晚，录制于“Vic Thrill沙龙”的视频中。“右岸”是一个没有舞台的拥挤小酒吧。人群呆呆地看着并跳着舞。Curly用双手紧紧握着麦克风，好像生怕有人会抢走它一样。
On nights like this, women occasionally threw their underwear at him. He had a song at a club jukebox. He'd become a local phenomenon. He stood out and at the same time began to fit in.
在这样的夜晚，女性有时会把内衣扔向他。他的歌上了俱乐部的点歌机。他成了一个当地的现象。他既与众不同，又开始融入其中。
I witnessed an accelerated adolescence with this guy. In the course of a year and a half, I watched the guy go from 13 to 20 years old.
我在这个家伙身上目睹了一场加速的青春期。在一年半的时间里，我看着他从13岁长到了20岁。
Deep inside a lot of people have, I would call, the beast of within. When you see sometimes people get drunk [UNINTELLIGIBLE], there's a moment that now they can be what they really want to be and nobody will accuse them of being that image. They would just do it. They would just be like crazy and throwing stuff. I would be insane. I would like doing certain sounds and stuff and dancing. I felt like doing whatever I intend on doing and nobody can stop me, and being appreciated for it.
在内心深处，很多人都有所谓的“内在野兽”。当你看到人们喝醉了的时候，总有一刻他们可以成为他们真正想成为的人，没人会指责他们。他们只是随心所欲，发疯似地扔东西。我会变得疯狂。我会发出奇怪的声音，跳舞。我觉得我可以做我想做的事，没人能阻止我，而且还能因此受到赞赏。
Was it satisfying?
那种感觉满足吗？
Absolutely. Hell yeah.
绝对的。太满足了。
He inspired everybody. He lit a fire under everybody's ass in this place. He was so unafraid. And I think you envied that. He hadn't been told yet that he was going too far in any way. And I think that a lot of people over the course of their lives, if you started at 13 years old, you may have been burned by some extremes here and there. And he hadn't been. And these are all little horses that we fail to get back on when we've been hurt. And he hadn't experienced that yet. And it definitely caused me to get back on some horses and not be so embarrassed and self conscious about the way I performed.
他激励了每个人。他在这个地方点燃了每个人的热情。他太无畏了。我想你嫉妒那一点。没人告诉过他，他在任何方面做得太过火了。我想很多人在人生历程中，如果你从13岁就开始尝试，可能会因为某些极端行为而碰壁。但他没有。这些都是我们受伤后不再敢骑上去的小马。但他还没经历过那些。这确实促使我重新骑上了一些马，不再对我的表演方式感到那么尴尬和自我意识过剩。
But the life of a Hasidic rocker has some built-in complications. Chaim dreamed about singing Welcome to the Millennium for a crowd of millions in Times Square on New Year's Eve of 2000. But he dropped that plan when he realized the date fell on the Sabbath when work was out of the question.
但哈西德摇滚明星的生活总有一些内在的复杂性。海姆梦想着在2000年除夕夜，在时代广场为数百万观众演唱《欢迎来到千禧年》。但当他意识到日期刚好在安息日时，他放弃了这个计划，因为那意味着得工作。
For a while, for more than a year in fact, he nurtured Curly Oxide. But he was a Hasid too. And he knew he couldn't be both people for very long. He began dropping hints to his parents about his secret life. And he got sloppy about concealing the evidence of his alter ego. His mother found lyrics in English that he left lying around. His father found a fan letter in the pocket of his pants. Plus he was coming home later and later, 3:00, 4:00, 5:00 in the morning. Sometimes his parents would be up waiting for him, distraught.
有一段时间，实际上超过一年，他悉心培养Curly Oxide这个角色。但他终究是个哈西德人。他知道他不可能长时间扮演两个角色。他开始向父母暗示他的秘密生活。而且在隐瞒 alter ego（另一个自我）的证据方面变得大意了。他母亲发现了他随手留下的英语歌词。他父亲在他裤兜里发现了粉丝来信。此外，他回家越来越晚，凌晨3点、4点、5点。有时父母会彻夜等他，非常焦虑。
My parents were like, you're killing me. You make me have a heart attack. It's not good for you. You're going to regret it. They tried to talk because they knew they couldn't go on in a strict way. Because they knew that any strict thing then do, I'm out. My dad wouldn't say anything. I would just dump myself into the bed. It would bother me. What am I doing. I would try to turn them off against those feelings. [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
我父母说，你在谋杀我们。你要害我得心脏病了。这对你没好处。你会后悔的。他们试图沟通，因为他们知道不能用强硬手段。因为他们知道任何严厉的限制，都会让我彻底跑掉。我爸爸什么都不说。我只是把自己甩到床上。这让我很烦。我到底在做什么。我试图压制内心的那些感受。
I started to actually get phone calls here. I had caller ID and I saw his last name on it. And he was here. And I was like, wow. I guess it's just started. Because I've seen Hasids go down to the Right Bank and pull Hasids out of there saying, you shouldn't be in there. And then argue with the people in there, non-Hasidic people arguing on behalf of the guy who was in there. And they say, you stay out of this. Stay out of this. This is none of your business. And I felt like, uh oh, this is about to happen with me.
我开始接到电话。我有来电显示，看到他的姓氏。他在那儿。我就想，哇，我想这事儿开始了。因为我见过哈西德人跑到“右岸”去把那里的哈西德人拉出来，说你不该在这儿。然后跟酒吧里的人，那些非哈西德人吵架，为那个被迫离开的家伙争辩。他们说，别插手。别插手，这不关你们的事。我觉得，噢噢，我这儿也要发生这种情况了。
Chaim's parents never confronted Vic. But they weren't about to lose their son without a fight. They began a massive hunt to find Chaim a wife as quickly as possible. They called everyone they knew, took recommendations from relatives. They networked with matchmakers.
海姆的父母从没跟比利对质。但他们绝不会轻易失去儿子。他们开始了一场大规模的搜索，想尽快给海姆找个妻子。他们联系了所有认识的人，听取亲戚的推荐。他们通过媒人建立关系网。
But Chaim was inching further and further away. He'd saved up some money. He was taking bartending classes. He had an exit strategy. Basically, the race was under way. His parents were trying to find him a wife before he actually left into the secular world for good. Oddly enough, the secular world seemed to be rooting for his parents.
但海姆正在一步步离去。他攒了一些钱。他在参加调酒课。他有退出策略。基本上，这场比赛已经开始了。他的父母正试图在他在世俗世界彻底离开之前找到一个妻子。奇怪的是，世俗世界似乎也在支持他的父母。
The one point he was going to cut the curls. He told me, he wanted to move in with me and he wanted to cut the curls. Jokingly, but with serious undertones, I said, if you cut the curls you're out of the band. I was like, I'm telling you man, if you cut the curls, we have no act. That's what I'm saying to you. Do you know what I'm saying?
有一次他打算剪掉卷发。他告诉我，他想搬来跟我住，想剪掉卷发。我开玩笑但带着严肃的口吻说，如果你剪了卷发，就别想待在乐队里了。我说，伙计，听着，如果你剪了卷发，我们的演出就全完了。
As the managerial type, as the music business type, the talent manager, I was mainly worried that the act was going to lose its luster if he became like us, and that it was going to turn to bad music. And the innocence, I think another big thing is that the innocence would be lost. And the innocence is where he was creating from. I just didn't want him to cross over entirely. I didn't want to be responsible for that.
作为管理方，作为音乐生意人，作为人才经理，我主要担心的是如果他变成我们这样，演出就会失去光彩，而且音乐会变得糟糕。还有一点，我想天真感也会随之消失。而天真正是他创作的源泉。我只是不想让他彻底跨界。我不想对此负责。
I could have gotten him on Howard Stern. Stern would have eaten that up. Part of me, like a selfish part of me, would have liked to have seen that. Stardom, of being a character, he was a prime candidate for that. But I didn't want to. I've heard that if a Hasid decides to cut the curls and leave the sect, I think they sit shiva actually. I think the parents sit shiva as if he's dead. So I didn't want to be the arch enemy of his family.
我本可以把他推上霍华德·斯特恩（Howard Stern）的节目。斯特恩肯定会对他感兴趣。我自私的一面本想看到那样。明星效应，做一个角色，他是最佳人选。但我没这么做。我听说，如果一个哈西德人决定剪掉卷发离开教派，他们会像对待死人一样为他守丧（sitting shiva）。所以我不想成为他家庭的头号敌人。
Chaim, as it happens, had reservations of his own about abandoning the Hasidic world.
巧的是，海姆本人对于放弃哈西德世界也有顾虑。
I was very torn. I was just torn. All along I knew that what I was doing was not in line with my upbringing, with the Hasidic way, with the Torah way of life. So I knew that I wasn't doing something right. But I liked it. And I felt that I was accepted. So I had these two paths. And I said, I can't choose. I don't know. I love both.
我很纠结。真的很纠结。自始至终，我知道我在做的不是我所受的教育，不是哈西德人的方式，也不是妥拉（Torah）的生活方式。所以我知道我做的事情不对。但我喜欢那样。我觉得自己被接受了。所以我面前有两条路。我说，我没法选。我不知道。我两边都爱。
As he said at one time, my parents are desperately trying to find me a wife. And I really want a record deal. But if they find me a wife first or if I get a record deal, it's God's will. And I'm going to do that.
正如他当时所说的：“我父母正拼命想给我找个妻子。我真的很想要一份唱片合约。但如果他们先帮我找到妻子，或者我先得到唱片合约，那都是上帝的旨意。我会照做。”
A record deal or a wife. If Chaim thought the choice was in the hand's of the Lord, he'd underestimated his mother, who called him one night while Chaim was in Manhattan getting ready for a show. A certain young lady would be at a certain wedding that evening, she told them. Maybe Chaim could swing by and take a look.
唱片合约还是妻子？如果海姆认为选择掌握在主的手里，那他就低估了他的母亲。一天晚上，当海姆正在曼哈顿准备演出时，她打来电话。她说，那位年轻女士今晚会出现在某场婚礼上。也许海姆可以去看看。
At first he said no, and begged offed with a few excuses. But his mother then sounded so sad. He felt a wave of guilt and reconsidered. Chaim changed back into his Hasidic clothes and went to the wedding, where he eventually got a quick glance at this young lady from a distance in a parking lot. Chaim was not impressed.
起初他说不，找借口推脱了。但后来他母亲听起来太伤心了。他感到一阵内疚，于是改变了主意。海姆换回了他的哈西德服装，去了婚礼，在那里他终于在停车场远远地看了一眼那位女士。海姆没留下什么好印象。
I was like, for this they made me again come. OK, another bust. So I went home. I said, for this? Next time before you send me somewhere get information on what we're talking about. So I went back down to the basement. I got back dressed. And I went to perform that night until 4 o'clock in the morning.
我想，就为了这个让我又跑了一趟。好吧，又是白忙一场。于是我回家了。我说，就为了这个？下次你在派我去哪儿之前，先搞清楚我们要谈的是什么。我又回到了地下室。我换回了演出服。然后我一直表演到凌晨4点。
But the girl felt differently. It turned out that she liked him. And that softened him just a little, enough to get Chaim to agree to a date, a Hasidic date in her living room surrounded by family.
但那个女孩的感觉不同。结果是她喜欢他。那让海姆的心软化了一点，足够让海姆同意约会，那种在家人环绕的客厅里的哈西德式约会。
My parents were sitting in the kitchen and there was no door. And I felt totally uncomfortable. They were talking about for maybe 45 minutes.
我父母坐在厨房里，那里没有门。我觉得非常不自在。我们谈了大约45分钟。
This is the first you'd spoken to her?
这是你第一次和她说话吗？
Right. There's not too much to converse. You went to the yeshiva. And when do you want the kids? And what do you want your kids to go to the yeshiva, and to which yeshiva? Because there's like all kinds of yeshivas and stuff. I wasn't crazy over it. Because I was in a totally different world at that time. Obviously I was Curly Oxide. And all of a sudden I'm put on back into this other personality. I was totally two different persons.
是的。没太多可聊的。你上了哪所经学院。你想什么时候生孩子。你想要孩子去哪所经学院，去哪一个？因为有很多各种各样的经学院。我并不怎么兴奋。因为当时我活在完全不同的世界里。很显然我是Curly Oxide。突然我又被塞回了另一种人格。我完全是两个不同的人。
The matchmaker goes in and talks to my mother and says, they want to finish it, tell me the girl wants me. That was it. I'm married. I have two beautiful children.
媒人进去跟我妈妈谈，说他们想定下来，告诉我女孩想要我。就是这样。我结婚了。我有两个可爱的孩子。
Now wait a second, wait a second. Let's back up. It was that quick?
等等，等等。让我们倒回去。就这么快？
Yeah. We spoke Saturday night. And we became engaged. There was an engagement party the next day.
是的。我们周六晚上谈话。然后我们就订婚了。第二天就办了订婚派对。
They were indeed married three months later. This might sound incredibly fast, but in the Hasidic tradition no one marries for love. That comes later hopefully. And Chaim had spent far more energy dreaming about the Billboard Charts than about being a husband, even in the back of his mind that a day of surrender was probably inevitable. And that it meant returning fully to the fold. No more rock star, no more carousing, the end of the beast within.
他们确实在三个月后就结婚了。这听起来快得不可思议，但在哈西德传统中，没有人是因为爱情而结婚。希望那是以后才有的。海姆花在梦想公告牌榜单上的精力远比做一个丈夫多得多，即便他内心深处明白，臣服的那一天很可能不可避免。这也意味着完全回归群体。没有摇滚明星，没有狂欢，结束了“内在的野兽”。
But you knew that you were killing Curly Oxide at that moment you agreed to get married?
但你同意结婚的那一刻，你就知道你要扼杀Curly Oxide了，对吗？
I knew that this character is going down, yeah. We knew that it was just like a show. We knew that the show is going to be up. And then there's going to be time to close it.
我知道这个角色完了，是的。我们知道那不过是一场演出。我们知道演出要结束了。然后就是谢幕的时间了。
Were you sad that that show's going to be over?
你为那场演出结束感到伤心吗？
I can put myself back in the moment, and I didn't think-- because my whole life can tumbling, because these two years, it was like so shaky. All of a sudden, OK, I came back. They're like, oh, you you are normal. You are getting married like everybody else. And I couldn't think. I didn't even realize what was happening.
我可以让自己回到那个时刻，我没想……因为我整个生活都崩塌了，那两年实在是太不稳定了。突然间，好了，我回来了。他们说，哦，你正常了。你像其他人一样结婚了。我无法思考。我甚至没意识到发生了什么。
Were you relieved?
你如释重负吗？
To an extent.
在某种程度上。
Billy, for his part, was kind of relieved too. And now having chaperoned Chaim through his world, he wanted at last to get a glimpse at Chaim's, which would be tricky.
至于比利，他也感到如释重负。现在带着海姆闯荡过他的世界后，他最后想一窥海姆的世界，但这很棘手。
You know, the toughest part of the whole thing was that he wasn't going to be able to invite me to the wedding.
你知道，整件事最难的部分在于，他没法邀请我去婚礼。
Because non-Hasidics are not allowed at the wedding?
因为非哈西德人不能参加婚礼？
Absolutely not. But we found a solution to that. We found a loophole to that soon enough, which was he hired Cass, Chris Cassidy, who was our videographer at the Vic Thrill's Salon, to film his wedding with me as the assistant. At the time, I had a green mohawk which I had to stuff under a hat. A yarmulke would not have concealed this thing.
绝对不能。但我们很快找到了一个解决方案，找到了一个漏洞。他雇了Cass，克里斯·卡西迪（Chris Cassidy），我们的摄像师，以我的助理的名义拍摄婚礼。当时，我留着绿色的莫霍克发型，我得把它塞进帽子里。小圆帽可遮不住这玩意儿。
So we went in there and we shot the wedding. And the wedding, that was really like the third stage on the divine gift of his friendship was to witness a Hasidic wedding. It was like nothing I had ever seen in my life, the fact that we got to see them married under the tent. It just seemed like such an ancient ceremony too, the ritual of it with her walking around him and the constant prayer that was going on. I really felt like the love for these two, and how important it was that everybody gather around them and pray all together. And then going into the building to watch them run down the hallway. And he's smiling. And I'm like, this is my old buddy man, he's smiling at me. I didn't realize that this was the turning point.
所以我们进了婚礼，拍了录像。婚礼现场，那是上帝赋予他友情的第三阶段，就是亲眼目睹一场哈西德婚礼。那是我这辈子见过最不可思议的东西，我们看到他们在帐篷下结婚。这看起来像是一场如此古老的仪式，仪式中她绕着他走，祈祷声不断。我真的感受到了这两人的爱，以及每个人围着他们共同祈祷是多么重要。走进建筑，看着他们跑下走廊。他在笑。我想，这就是我的老伙计，他在冲我笑。我没意识到这才是转折点。
They turned off into a room. And that's where they go to consummate the marriage. A small room, I think, with a bed in it. And everybody just eats out in the hall, out in the dining hall, which has a partition down the middle of it. And the men are on one side and the women are on the other side.
他们转进了一个房间。那就是他们去完成婚姻（洞房）的地方。一个小房间，我想，里面有张床。其他人就在大厅里吃东西，餐厅里隔着一道隔板。男人们在一边，女人们在另一边。
So we had to leave the hall at that point when they had gone to the room. And we were invited back in when they were being carried out on the chairs. And they placed down in their separate rooms there. And they have to dance with everybody in the room. He danced with hundreds of guys. I mean, it's incredible, the energy that you have to put out on your wedding night if you're Hasidic is just incredible.
所以他们进屋时，我们必须离开大厅。当他们被椅子抬出来时，我们又被邀请进去了。他们被放在各自的房间里。然后他们必须和屋里的每个人跳舞。他跟几百个男人跳了舞。我是说，难以置信，如果你是哈西德人，你在婚礼之夜需要付出的精力真是不可思议。
Now his father had suspected something of me. Because a few of the Hasidic guys at the wedding had winked at me and come up and elbowed me. They knew me from the legend of Curly Oxide. Several of them had gone down to the Right Bank because his song was on the jukebox. They heard about that. And so this guy was like a legend in his neighborhood. And they were coming up to me. And I think the father saw some of this going on. And he would give me what I call the skunk eye every once in a while. He gave me like this hairy eyeball. And I zoomed in on him every time he'd do that. So I had this up close footage of the hairy eyeball from his father. It was incredible.
当时他父亲对我起疑了。因为婚礼上有几个哈西德人对我眨眼，走过来用手肘顶我。他们从Curly Oxide的传奇故事里知道我。他们中有几个人去过“右岸”，因为他的歌在点歌机里。他们听说过这事儿。所以这个家伙简直是他们社区里的传奇。他们走过来找我。我想他父亲看到了这些。他偶尔会给我那种我称之为“臭鼬眼神”的瞪视。他就像是在给我一个“毛茸茸的眼球”（瞪眼）。我每次都会把镜头推到他脸上。所以我有他父亲那种瞪视的近距离录像。太不可思议了。
At the very end of the whole thing, I walked up to him. Because everybody was shaking his hand at that point. And Cass shook his hand. And I walk up and I shook his hand like a total stranger. And we had zero energy transferred between us in the old way. You know, we really blocked it off. Congratulations man, she seems like a beautiful bride. And that was it. And we had a big laugh boy, afterwards though when he showed up here. I mean we laughed for like half an hour over this whole thing.
这一切结束时，我走到他面前。因为当时每个人都在跟他握手。Cass跟他握了手。我也走过去像个陌生人一样跟他握手。我们之间没有那种老方式的能量传达。你知道，我们真的封闭了。祝贺你哥们，她看起来是个漂亮的新娘。就这样。不过在他后来出现在我们这儿之后，我们大笑了一场，笑得人仰马翻。我是说，我们为了这件事笑了半个多小时。
Years after that half hour laugh, Billy Campion is touring at Vic Thrill playing shows around New York and throughout Europe. If you ever catch his act, you'll witness a guy as antic as anyone you'll ever see on stage. Pager on vibrate is how one observer put it. The unembarrassable style owes a little something to Curly Oxide.
在那半小时大笑几年后，比利·坎皮恩正带着Vic Thrill巡演，在纽约和欧洲各地演出。如果你看过他的表演，你会看到一个舞台上比任何人都要活跃的人。“震动传呼机”是某位观察家对他的评价。这种“不怕丢脸”的风格，多多少少得归功于Curly Oxide。
In the months after the wedding, every once in awhile, Billy and Chaim would get together just to catch up. But almost immediately, Chaim and his family moved an hour upstate. Now he doesn't see Billy much. In part he relocated to avoid the temptations of his old ways. Then again, he doesn't sound like a man on the verge of a back slide.
婚礼后的几个月里，偶尔，比利和海姆会聚在一起叙旧。但几乎立即，海姆和他的家人搬到了一个小时外的北部。现在他很少见比利了。部分原因是他搬家是为了避免老习惯的诱惑。话又说回来，他听起来不像是一个处于堕落边缘的人。
I didn't even want to think of missing it, because I'm missing it. Meaning I'm not there, so why even go there to feel missing it. You blank out. You try. You blank yourself out. I mean, I know that I can't have. But you know what I would like over there. And I like my life now. And I would lose everything going back. There's too much to lose. And I know that I can't have it. So I wouldn't even touch that.
我甚至不想去想错过了什么，因为我确实错过了。意思是说，我不在那儿，那何必去想那种失落感呢。你把它抹去。你尝试。你让自己一片空白。我是说，我知道我无法拥有那些。但你知道我想要那儿的什么。我喜欢我现在的日子。回到过去我会失去一切。损失太大了。我知道我无法拥有它。所以我甚至不去触碰它。
Does your wife know that you had this other life as Curly Oxide. Yes, she actually does. I told him. I actually regret telling it. Because let me tell you, if don't know if you guys are married. But anybody that is married, do not tell you wife your past, especially your troubled past, I mean the stuff that you did, your mischief past.
你妻子知道你曾有另一段Curly Oxide的生活吗？是的，她确实知道。我告诉他了。其实我很后悔告诉她。因为让我告诉你，如果你们结婚了，别告诉妻子你的过去，尤其是那些麻烦的过去，我是说你做过的事情，你的捣乱历史。
I asked Chaim, would he tell his son if the boy announced one day if he wanted to sing in a rock band. Chaim almost frowned. I'd tell him to sing something traditional, he said, and songs that are Yiddish. As for Curly Oxide, there's hardly a trace of his career anywhere. He never released a CD. And last year the Right Bank closed. And that unplugged the only jukebox in the world where you could hear his music.
我问海姆，如果他的儿子哪天宣布想去摇滚乐队唱歌，他会告诉他吗？海姆皱起了眉头。我说我会让他唱些传统的歌，他说，唱意第绪语的歌。至于Curly Oxide，他的职业生涯几乎没留下任何痕迹。他从未发行过CD。去年“右岸”关闭了。那也拔掉了世界上唯一能听到他音乐的点歌机的电源。
David Segal is a staff writer for the Washington Post . He also has a website, www.jewsrock.org.
大卫·西格尔是《华盛顿邮报》的特约撰稿人。他也有一个网站，www.jewsrock.org。
[MUSIC - "CE-5" BY VIC THRILL]
[音乐 - Vic Thrill的《CE-5》]
Act Two, Miami Vices. This next story was recorded as a live stage show in Los Angeles called Mortified, in which everyday people stand up on stage and read from their own teenage diaries. One person took the stage one night with Sascha Rothchild. A quick warning for sensitive listeners, that she mentions all kinds of fooling around with teenage boys in what follows.
第二幕，“迈阿密罪恶”。接下来的这个故事是在洛杉矶的一场名为“Mortified”的现场舞台秀上录制的，普通人在舞台上朗读自己的青春期日记。那天晚上，莎莎·罗斯柴尔德（Sascha Rothchild）登台了。给敏感听众一个简短的警告，接下来提到的内容涉及她和少年男孩之间各种胡闹行为。
Hi everybody. My name is Sascha. And to give you a little background, I grew up in a very upper class, Jewish household in Miami Beach. And I went to elementary school. For elementary school, I went to private school. And I hated it because the kids were really mean to me.
大家好。我叫莎莎。稍微介绍一下背景，我在迈阿密海滩一个非常上流的犹太家庭长大。小学时，我上的是私立学校。我讨厌那里，因为孩子们对我非常刻薄。
So I really wanted to go to public school for junior high, and my parents let me. And this is what happened when I went to public school. And I'm 13 here.
所以我非常想去公立学校上初中，我父母同意了。这就是我上公立学校后发生的事。那时我13岁。
A lot happened today. I made out five times with Jose Pola. He said, I kiss like a rich girl. He had the longest tongue. I really like his best friend, Carlos. I think Carlos likes me. Jose and I are just good friends. But we fool around because we think each other is hot.
今天发生了很多事。我和何塞·波拉（Jose Pola）亲热了五次。他说，我亲起来像个富家女。他的舌头超长。我真的很喜欢他的好朋友卡洛斯。我觉得卡洛斯也喜欢我。我和何塞只是好朋友。但我们胡闹是因为我们觉得彼此很火辣。
I'm reading The Diary of Anne Frank. It really means a lot to me. First of all, I'm Jewish and that means a lot to me. Also, I recently got you and started writing in you. The Diary of Anne Frank has really inspired me. Anyway, Carlos and I finally made out.
我正在读《安妮日记》。它对我意义重大。首先，我是犹太人，这对我很重要。另外，最近我有了你（日记本），并开始在上面写字。《安妮日记》真的激励了我。总之，卡洛斯和我终于亲热了。
Jessica is being a bitch. After I was with Carlos, I spent some time with Tyrone, Treyant and Tyrell. I love them. I like black boys much more than white boys. They're more fun. It gets worse.
杰西卡真是个贱人。和卡洛斯在一起后，我和泰隆（Tyrone）、特雷恩特（Treyant）还有泰瑞尔（Tyrell）混在一起。我爱他们。我比白人男孩更喜欢黑人男孩。他们更有趣。情况更糟了。
So much has happened. I went to a big party at Gira's house. The party was awesome. I got completely drunk and started talking to these older guys who had beer. They gave me a lot. The older guys liked me and they wanted my phone number. I gave it to them.
发生了太多事。我去了吉拉家的一个大派对。派对棒极了。我喝得烂醉，开始和那些有啤酒的年长男孩聊天。他们给了我很多。那些年长男孩喜欢我，还想要我的电话号码。我给了他们。
I'm worried though. I'm turning into a bad girl. My grades are dropping, I'm drinking a lot, I'm lying, et cetera. I don't want to tell Diego and Shane I'm only 13, but I also don't want to get raped or anything. I don't know what to do. I think I'm going to lose my virginity very soon. The scary thing is is that I'm having so much fun. So many guys like me. I'm so [BLEEP] popular. My mind and body are 17, but I'm only 13. P.S. I have grown so much inside in the past few months.
但我很担心。我正在变成坏女孩。我的成绩在下滑，我喝了很多酒，我在撒谎等等。我不想告诉迪耶戈和谢恩我才13岁，但我也没想被强奸什么的。我不知道该怎么办。我觉得我很快就要失去贞操了。可怕的是我居然玩得这么开心。这么多男孩喜欢我。我真他妈的受欢迎。我的思想和身体已经17岁了，但我才13岁。附言：过去几个月我内在成长了很多。
Hey, what's up or down? I put the arrows up or down. Well, things are totally up with me. Helder and I are going out. I like him so much. He's so cool, nice, funny, caring, sensitive, and [BLEEP] fine. He has such a nice body. In the movie, Helder and I made out a lot and we went to second over the shirt. It wasn't a big deal. Later dude. I wrote later dude literally.
嘿，怎么了？（我在日记旁标了上下箭头）。嗯，我的情况非常棒。赫尔德（Helder）和我正在交往。我非常喜欢他。他太酷了，人好、幽默、体贴、敏感，而且他妈的帅。他身材真好。在电影里，我和赫尔德亲热了很多，隔着衬衫发生了二垒行为。没什么大不了的。回头见。我真的是写了“回头见”（Later dude）。
OK, a lot happened. First of all, Helder and I broke up yesterday. I dumped him, in parentheses. The day after we went out, and went to his house and we were in bed naked together. Don't ask me how that happened. I wouldn't sleep with him and I think he got mad.
好吧，发生了很多事。首先，赫尔德和我昨天分手了。我甩了他。（括号中写着）。我们交往后的第二天，去了他家，我们在床上赤身裸体在一起。别问我那是怎么发生的。我没让他跟我发生性关系，我想他生气了。
Since then, it seemed all Helder wanted was to have sex with me. I broke up with him six days after we went out. Aye, literally aye-- because I'm hanging out with Cubans-- so I'm trying to understand how to speak Spanish. Well a lot of [BLEEP] [BLEEP] has happened. I have been getting drunk and stoned everyday. Also, Diego and I broke up. I didn't mind that he was a drug dealer, but it just wasn't working out anyway.
从那时起，赫尔德似乎只想跟我发生性关系。我们在交往六天后分手了。Aye（“呀”，字面意思）——因为我老跟古巴人混，所以我正在尝试学西班牙语。嗯，发生了好多他妈的烂事。我每天都在喝醉和吸毒。另外，迪耶戈和我分手了。我不介意他是毒贩，但这本来就没戏。
Anna and I aren't friends anymore. Cricket and I are very good friends. And last but not least I'm going out with Antonio. We have been together for nine days. I really like him. I'm planning on sleeping with him. Oh, and I tried cocaine.
安娜和我不再是朋友了。蟋蟀（Cricket）和我成了好朋友。最后但同样重要的是，我正在和安东尼奥交往。我们在一起九天了。我真的很喜欢他。我打算和他发生性关系。哦，我还尝试了可卡因。
It's the coolest [BLEEP] thing on earth. I think I'm addicted. Oh well.
这是地球上最酷的他妈的东西。我想我上瘾了。唉，随它去吧。
And the downfall continues. Antonio and I got into our first big fight last night. What a temper! We made up though. I like the way he makes me feel. I'm the woman and should be kept in my place. Of course he is a Cuban. Well, I got to go change my tampon. At least I'm not pregnant yet.
坠落继续。安东尼奥和我昨晚第一次大吵了一架。脾气真大！但我们和好了。我喜欢他带给我的感觉。我是女人，就该待在我的位置上。当然，他是个古巴人。好吧，我得去换卫生棉条了。至少我还没怀孕。
What's up, yo-- literally in the diary, what's up yo? I have done flake five times today. For those of you who don't know, flake is a pseudonym for cocaine if you're not cool. I have done flake five times today. I loved all of them. I'm not doing any more, for now at least. I like it too much. The high is worth the low. I'm also trying to stop smoking pot. I'm getting really burnt. Instead I'm smoking cigarettes and shoplifting. I love it. I get such a head rush. Today I stole three pairs of underwear, one bra, and two shirts. It was too easy. We're nearing the end.
怎么了，Yo——日记里写的原话是“怎么了，Yo”？我今天吸了五次Flake。对于那些不知道的人，Flake是可卡因的代称，如果你不够酷的话就不知道。我今天吸了五次Flake。我爱死它们了。我不会再吸了，至少现在不会。我太喜欢它了。高峰值得低谷。我也在尝试停止抽大麻。我快抽废了。取而代之我开始抽烟和在店里偷东西。我爱死它了。我能感受到强烈的头晕目眩。今天我偷了三条内裤、一个胸罩和两件衬衫。太容易了。快到结局了。
Oh my god. It has to stop. It all has to stop. I'm going to change my life around. I snorted two huge bumps and then I came down hard, real hard. The high isn't worth the low anymore. I have to stop hanging out with these people. I'm going to [BLEEP] up my life. I'm scared, really scared.
天哪。这一切必须停止。这一切都得停止。我要改变我的生活。我吸了两大口，然后我掉下来了，掉得很惨。高峰再也不值得那个低谷了。我得停止和这些人混在一起。我会毁掉我的生活。我很害怕，真的。
OK, this is a month later. Hi, I'm still alive and not pregnant yet. I broke up with Antonio and I'm going to NA. I've been off cocaine and pot since October 2. I'm doing really good. I'm still having fun without totally going crazy. I think I'm going to sleep with Jason. I really want to because he's so hot and he thinks I'm hot. so many people do.
好吧，这已经是之后一个月了。嘿，我还活着，还没怀孕。我和安东尼奥分手了，我在参加戒毒互助会（NA）。我从10月2日开始没碰可卡因和大麻了。我做得很好。我依然在没有发疯的情况下玩得很开心。我想我打算和杰森（Jason）发生性关系。我真的想，因为他太火辣了，他也觉得我火辣。很多人都这么觉得。
I'm so popular and scandalous. I'm leaving out so many details that I hope I don't forget. But my hand would hurt if I wrote them all down. It's time for a new diary, but this one will always be most memorable. Later dude.
我是如此受欢迎且令人震惊。我省略了太多细节，希望我不会忘记。但如果把它们都写下来，我的手会疼的。是时候换一本新日记了，但这一本将永远是最难忘的。回头见。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Sascha Rothchild is still not pregnant. She graduated from high school drug free and with honors. She's now married, a writer living in Los Angeles. She was recorded at a show called Mortified. Thanks to David Nadelberg who runs the show. More info at www.getmortified.com.
莎莎·罗斯柴尔德依然没有怀孕。她以优异的成绩从高中毕业，远离毒品。她现在结婚了，是个住在洛杉矶的作家。这段录音是在一场叫“Mortified”的秀上录制的。感谢经营该节目的戴维·纳德伯格（David Nadelberg）。更多信息请访问www.getmortified.com。
Our program was produced today by Jane Feltes and myself with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Sarah Koenig, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Will [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
今天的节目由简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、黛安·库克（Diane Cook）、莎拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）和丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）参与。资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼（Todd Bachmann）和威尔[名字听不清]提供了制作协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际（PRI）发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia who can be heard at bars all over Chicago walking up to young people and saying--
WBEZ对我们节目的管理由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，他可以在芝加哥的各个酒吧里被听到，他走到年轻人面前说——
I have a recording studio up the street. I would love to have you by some time if you really want to get these recordings down, you know what I mean, in a quality way?
我在街上有个录音棚。如果你真的想好好录音的话，我很乐意你什么时候过来，你懂我意思吧，录出那种高质量的作品？
Hey, worked on me. Back next week with more quality recordings of This American Life .
嘿，这对我管用。下周再见，带来更多《美国生活》的高质量录音。
[MUSIC]
[音乐]
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。